all right here we go
today we are um you know we have the
pleasure of sort of having this
impromptu
conversation with jason brubacher of
filmmakerstuff.com
um he's a filmmaker we just discovered
you know
we're gonna we're gonna check and see if
this is right or not but we believe he
might be involved with distributor i
mean he
he really knows you know he's a speaker
yeah thank you thank you you know
he knows he knows film distribution
inside and out it's a pleasure to have
him join
us yes jason let's just start off can
you give us a little bit on your
background and sort of where your focus
has been
in the past year yeah i'll give you a
little bit of the background and then
i'll talk about the past year
about 12 years ago like a lot of us and
and probably like
you both i started this filmmaking thing
with the idea you know no other vocation
appealed to me more than going out and
making movies and hopefully making some
money and making my living making movies
and that that um desire took me to new
york city where i worked
with an independent film producer and we
made a few features and what i quickly
realized up there was um
i'm from pennsylvania originally so what
i quickly realized was
making the movies just part of the
process even though that's the thing you
dream about and most filmmakers do
when it comes to actually making a movie
a success you have to have some sort of
distribution in place
and what happened for us is we had a
great festival run and then when it came
time for distribution
we got a whole bunch of offers but none
of the offers were deals
because deals actually pay money and our
offers although it would have been nice
to be in the video stores which
you know by the way most of them aren't
even in existence anymore um
it would have been nicer to be able to
pay the bills making movies and that was
so frustrating to me
that it just created this thinking i was
like if i could only overcome this
distribution hurdle
then i could have a complete business so
fast forward to now
i moved out to california i got together
with a bunch of folks
we made our first feature and i went
through the whole brigham reward trying
to find distribution it was the same
thing we had a lot of offers
no deals but it was around 2006
when we were able to go to market so we
just thought why don't we just do the
test put this thing on amazon and see
what happens
it was a silly zombie movie but to our
benefit
it gained somewhat of a cult following
and so we made a sale and we were like
oh my gosh we just made a sale
and another sale another sale another
sale and it totally changed my paradigm
uh the way i think about distribution
and that that was a huge
you know that was a turning point for me
so now when i go out on these speaking
gigs i'm always talking about like
hey cut out the middle man you don't
need the middleman just go straight to
the market
which works for it it may not work for
everybody but it works for a heck of a
lot of ambitious filmmakers out there
it gives us some freedom so wow that's
interesting
do you think a lot of people though are
as business-minded as you are you seem
like you have sort of both
equations in your brain i think a lot of
people sway more towards the creative
though
i think the creative's fun because you
get all sorts of bells and whistles and
i know a lot of filmmakers will go out
and
buy the latest greatest camera and audio
equipment and they'll put in their
closet just so they can look at it
and i know that very well because i used
to be that guy and i'm like oh look i'm
a filmmaker look at that stuff in my
closet
but it doesn't no good and
and so you need the business stuff to
actually get your work out there into
the world so i kind of had to learn it
um and maybe i talk about it way too
much you know it's a little nerdy
but i try to make it fun well there's
nothing nerdy about making money you
know and and
i'm wondering do you have that um sort
of background from
college or were you more of an artistic
major what was your
quality yeah in college i was i was a
theater arts major it was the closest i
could get to filmmaking but it wasn't
until i got to new york when i was
working with that producer that i heard
the word business plan for the first
time
i was like business plan um i did grow
up
my dad had a small business growing up
so i did learn a little bit about
you know if you have a product or
service you have to sell that and you
have to get it out of the world
and then i sold spas when i was in
college and
um i have a lot of sales background so
maybe it's kind of
integrated it you know into my life but
the whole reason i got a sales job
selling spas in college
was so that i could make enough money to
make my first uh short film
so it all kind of worked together oh
nice
and so sort of update us on your journey
jason in terms of where you find
yourself now sort of in the past year
uh where where is your focus been well
yeah i will say that after that zombie
movie came out i did have a job
with a with an investment bank called
lehman brothers and that was one of the
big
banks that went under and i'm sure
you're laughing so you've probably heard
that name a few times since 2008.
yeah well and and that admittedly helped
me because i knew some folks with some
money and stuff so that helped us make
that zombie movie having that position
and knowing some of those people
but the whole thing on the distribution
getting it out into amazon
when i found myself without that great
source of income i was like what do i do
next
and i would get these emails from
filmmakers that had heard about the
amazon thing and they were like hey
how'd you do that
and that was the impetus to starting
filmmaking stuff so i just started
writing these articles late night which
grew in a whole website and and we bring
it up to date now and it's
it has some popularity but one of the
things that came up
um in that uh sort in that journey was
hey i want to get my movie out on itunes
how do i do that
and it was somewhere around a year about
three years ago i reached out to adam
chapnick over at distributor and i was
like hey
you guys have a pretty neat service here
i want to promote that to my folks i
think you guys could help a lot of my
people
and that created the relationship
between adam and i
and what happened now is that evolved
and i'm now the
director of operations over at
distributor so for the past
six months i've actually been helping a
lot of the filmmakers that i formally
brought in through filmmaking stuff so
it's a small world
oh very cool wow that's just really neat
you know you know and we've been huge
sort of advocates of distributor and
it's really great to hear you know your
path to distributor and what you're
doing now
you know i think that's wonderful yeah
i'm happy you know i'm happy to get into
any
any of that kind of stuff and for those
of us watching this
this is an unscripted interview so i
want to make sure that we cover some of
the things that you guys want to cover
um word out on the street is you have a
movie right now speaking of distribution
you guys are looking to distribute tell
tell us about that
yeah no you know what we're doing is
um you know the same kind of thing
you're talking about in terms of just
having a product
um you know wanting to get it to people
without the middleman
and you know looking at you know looking
at film festivals looking at traditional
distribution and all this sort of thing
and just seeing that nothing there is
necessarily promised
you know we have a really small film you
know we don't we don't pretend to be
that this is something this is some
massive film we have a really small film
that we made
that we didn't have a production budget
when we started we
crowdfunded about sixteen thousand
dollars of which
we ended up with about fourteen thousand
nine hundred that we use for post
production
um to help pay with those costs um and
so
we spent a long time making the film we
did we didn't want to like sort of slow
down momentum on our release
going any other way we want to try to
figure out a way to use the existing
tools
um and without having to put in even
more money because the thing is with
filmmaking
it's like one way or another you just
end up putting more and more money and
we just like you know what
is there any way where we can just get
the film to people so people can access
it all over the world
there's no more money out of our pockets
and we're able to start generating some
momentum so there's a lot of reasons
um you know you know you won't answer
anything you have for us in terms of why
indiegogo or whatever um but you know we
started looking at the excitement
happening on
crowdfunding platforms it's gotten to
the point now where we're
um funding before you have your product
is more exciting than the actual
distribution like when you actually have
the product the film's made you're
excited you're like
yes i can't wait to share this people
see my work and yet
it's kind of like a dud it's kind of
like a thought it's just like where's
the excitement that that social
component
component the engagement um
all the kind of stuff that we saw you
know happening with crowdfunding is not
happening
with distribution yet and so you know we
started getting this idea in our head
like what if what if we
and i just want to take a step back here
because i'm going to share this over on
filmmaking stuff and a lot of those
folks maybe this might be their first
introduction to you guys
at film courage um let me know what film
courage is
firstly and then secondly take a step
back and you'd mention a couple
crowdfunding campaigns so why don't you
tell us
about the movie um your first
crowdfunding campaign and then
let us know why you chose to do a second
crowdfunding
campaign for your distribution as a
major component of your distribution
strategy
sure well thank you jason well um film
courage
is a radio show uh that was on
ellietalkradio.com
and we began it in april 2009
as a way to just talk about some of our
projects and then
it sort of took on a life of its own and
then we started a website
on uh 10 10 10 was october 10th
of 2010 and again uh articles came in
and we just got excited about hearing
other people's stories doing radio shows
about other people's journeys
and we really thrived off of sort of
this up and down ride that a lot of
these
individuals took in terms of you know
sort of
instant sort of fame or or just a hit
and then the rug was pulled out and they
had to kind of rebuild
and so we enjoyed hearing stories of
people getting back on the horse so to
speak
and and you know thriving once again um
so you know can i add to that you know
because really sort of the impetus of
film courage was
you know being filmmakers ourselves
having a film this you know goodbye
promise
the film that we're distributing on
indiegogo this is our second feature
our first feature night before the
wedding we were trying to promote you
know we're trying to get the word out
about it and and really there was there
was limited
options you know um in terms of in terms
of this kind of shows or
or websites that we wanted to be
featured on you know in terms of just an
independent film
sort of landscape so we kind of began
film courage with that in mind you know
like as a place where
you know we could share the work of
other filmmakers like us so
that was kind of like how it was born
yeah so it took on a life of its own and
then
at the same time uh we began uh filming
goodbye promise which is a story of an
actor
who comes here from virginia and he
gives himself
uh seven years to quote make it or cut
his losses and go home or go on to
something else
so the movie begins what a week before
that seven day deadline
or seven year deadline i'm sorry and uh
he's not where he wants to be in his
career
and so he has to kind of look at some of
his life choices and the people around
him
uh who dearly love him and and consider
is this worth fighting for
so i mean the film is is a lot like our
own lives and many people
around us so a lot of it was uh life
imitating art and art imitating life it
was a big mixture of stuff
and uh it took three years to complete
uh we launched our crowdfunding campaign
was it april
2010 i believe it was march or march
okay sorry and uh you know crowdfunding
was relatively new
some people knew about you know
kickstarter indiegogo um
but uh so you know we always joke about
it now have we
launched the campaign today we're not
sure if we would have had the same
success
even though we have a you know small
following
um but it's just gotten that much
tougher to compete for
for people's attention on the internet
and for ten dollars here five dollars
there so
um in terms of doing a lot of
competition in the crowdfunding space
right now
is that what you're seeing out there
absolutely and there's beautiful
projects i mean
what was the one you were telling me
about last night in uh australia
i think it's called second coming i i
gotta i gotta get the title i gotta
track this
this movie down and there's this
filmmakers
um from wish you were here australian
um it's a sundance film it's done it's
done really well in the past year
and now the producers of that film are
teaming up there's this australian
collaborative
i think it's called second coming movie
um but
the campaign video for that is
phenomenal you know you see such
tremendous work out there but to answer
your questions jason about
why indiegogo like why crowdfund again
for the release of the film
yeah so just to be clear you you guys
made this film you finished it did you
do a festival run with this
as well or is this oh no we had a one
week screening in la at the downtown
independent
okay yeah yeah yeah we we've had a
one-week theatrical run
in los angeles and we decided to bypass
film festivals we decided to bypass
um going going after traditional
distribution we decided that we're gonna
put the power in our own hands
and we're going we're gonna you know
we've made the film available for one
dollar
um people can access the film online
through indiegogo through youtube
it's it's using it's using indiegogo as
the storefront and then using youtube on
the back end where people can stream it
instantly
so this gives us distribution to the
entire world and we've had people
in 17 different countries so far
access the film which which has been
which has been really exciting for us
and in terms of a numbers point of view
which really was really fascinating is
we're offering the film for one dollar
and yet now we have
over 300 people who have supported the
film and supported the campaign
and the average contribution is 8.40
kind of like blows us away we never
anticipated that sort of ratio
we were hoping to get a lot more people
but we weren't thinking that sort of
average in terms of
you know eight times the you know the
dollar amount which is just insane to us
that's insane to any to any market or
you know speaking from a marketing
standpoint that's uh
it's pretty wild yeah you know why can i
just ask you
why did you decide to bypass some of the
traditional stuff and just say you know
what
forget the festivals forget trying to go
after a traditional deal
let's just really try to figure out a
way to get it out there to the masses
you know without anybody else yeah i
think i think what it is
is is um you know i think festivals are
our blessing and a curse
you know i think as filmmakers we get
caught up with the accolades
with the official selections with being
accepted and we feel like
wow my career is being formed um
and there's a lot of not to say that
there's not a lot of great stuff that
comes from from being in film festivals
and attending and meeting people and
everything
um but each time i mean number one
i mean to sum it up quickly the main
thing is just the time it takes from the
beginning of the film festivals all the
way through the end of your run
and it's like where are you really going
to end up at the end of the day that's
what i'm really concerned about is where
are you going to be with your film
if if those you know you said yourself
you had a lot of offers that came in
you didn't get the deals you were
looking for you know so now
you know we wanted to capitalize on as
much momentum from the start of our
release
as we could you know because your film
is only white hot once
you know and our film is really small we
don't have the money the resources
for a long one-year rollout hoping to
build momentum
and then stop and then start and then
stop and then start
we had to try to just hit the internet
all at once because
the internet is viral you know it's like
i i you know we'd rather put our energy
into the internet where people can
access it all over the world and have
that be our film festival
rather than trying to promote the kansas
city film festival
or the or or the tampa bay film fest you
know just
you know then only a small amount of
people can access our film you know we
you know
we just consider the internet one big
film festival we would like to reach as
many people as we possibly can
um so that that's the distinction there
yeah and we thought this was a great way
to do it with really no upfront cost for
us you know we'd already spent money on
the film
to finish it to shoot it everything why
not just try this
no no aggregator costs nothing so it was
sort of
an experiment and a way to sort of test
our audience and
and we feel very happy with it i mean
the amount that we've raised so far
is not substantial but what we are happy
with is the
reach and and the amount of people that
have tweeted it and
to us i think that means more what are
you doing on on your side i often say in
my talks that
whenever you're doing the things that
you're doing which um
i think there's a helicopter after me or
something
hopefully it's not blasting me out here
fun of los
angeles right yeah exactly when
so i always think you know you've you've
sourced an audience you've gotten your
name out there pretty significantly in
this project
are you doing anything on your end to
build those relationships for not just
this title but your next titles
that's a great point yeah do you want to
start on that one well the thing is
with every contributor pretty much i
think we get an email address
there might be an exception of just a
few but uh indiegogo gives us those
email addresses so there we have a way
to market to them
a month from now whenever if we have
maybe the dvd come out whatever it is
um and and we try to get back to as many
people as we can i'm sure there's been
people that have slipped through the
cracks and we feel
badly about that we try to reply to
people and i find that that's a pretty
good method is is trying to even if it's
a quick email that just says great
thanks
and i know it people hate one or two
word emails but sometimes
that's all you can do at least you
acknowledge that i've heard you
and and i got it and thank you so much
and so we just try to keep in contact
like that and
yeah yeah i mean you know it's been
pretty massive i mean it's wow because
like i said we we only have 300 actual
contributors
um which you know i guess in many fronts
it seems like such a small number
but when you're literally engaging with
that many people you know
when people are are commenting on the
film and the feedback that's pouring in
from
like different parts of the world
there's just a lot of engagement so
there's there's been a lot of
um tweeting back and forth on twitter
there's been a lot of um
commenting and sharing on facebook um so
yeah so we're directly interacting with
people and
and um you know we're starting from the
ground up even though we have the film
courage
platform that we've spent several years
building
you know this release is something brand
new this is something people haven't
seen so it's just like
you know we're like the frontline
soldiers that are just like okay let's
go we're
going to try to you know dodge bullets
and just and just try to create as much
man
or whatever not creating him but boyd
mayhem and
yeah you know we're disrupting the whole
thing right now and there may have been
someone resembling me walking around
hollywood and glendale in different
areas dropping off short films of david
that just happened to have the indiegogo
link
because these films were collecting dust
and it was one of david's first
short films entitled shootout and so we
thought what a great way to get rid of
them and just
accidentally leave them at a red box or
different things so
that was moi walking around and and
people were definitely like what is this
woman doing they thought it was probably
you know some type of church literature
or whatever they didn't want to be
bothered but i would just leave them
places
and then i would come back and they'd be
gone so i don't know if that really
works in terms of getting people to
donate a dollar
i think most of people have been through
the film courage um
circle but we have heard from people
like some guy tweeted us to say that he
heard people talking about it at
starbucks
in hollywood this online release he
heard another guy
today emailed us and said oh a waitress
at a coffee shop that he goes to
heard about the film to the la times so
we're just trying to build buzz and i
think
for us right now that means more than
the money yeah
well speaking of the money we are
getting down to the wire with your
crowdfunding campaign
and you guys are doing something
interesting here in the sense
you're not raising money to actually
create the film
you're raising money to get it out into
the marketplace and help promote the
film
why do you think the response has has
been
less significant on this side of the
crowd funding
versus the one you did initially to
raise the money
well you know but the thing is i don't
know if i don't know if it is less
significant you know i mean
i mean i mean the thing is we're not
asking we don't have the 50
perks we don't have the 75 perks so you
know for a lot of crowdfunding campaigns
for every contributor
you know that they'll average somewhere
between 25 and 75
a contribution you know so you know our
average is eight dollars but once again
our only perk is the film itself for a
dollar so we're not we're not asking for
a lot
and there's a lot of ways to sort of
measure what we're doing so far i mean
you know
one way to look at it is let's say this
was our festival premiere you know
because
our campaign it says 30 days but i think
in actuality i think it's maybe 32 days
so if you're getting ready for your
festival premiere and if you're
promoting like hey guys you know what
we're going to be at the the seattle
true independent film festival
and you're promoting that for 30 days
you know when you actually screen at
that festival how many people are
actually going to pay and buy tickets
and show up for that for that festival
you know during during that first
promotional run are you going to get 300
people to show for your screening
you know i i don't know so it all
depends how you want to you know what
you what you want to gauge
as the thing you know and as karen
mentioned we we're building a small
email list to start that we can come
back and maybe offer the dvd to at a
later point
so there's a lot of different ways in
terms of what you want to look at the
number if you don't if you don't just
only focus on on the on the two thousand
dollars or 2600 or whatever
whatever it is right now um that's one
way to look at it but the engagement the
awareness reaching people all over the
world
um i believe there's a lot of ways to
sort of measure the early success and i
think
the reason why we maybe hasn't fully
caught on yet is is
as people aren't haven't seen this yet
before you know and and
and also we're not we're not done yet
you know we still we still have till
wednesday
so you know if you know crowdfunding as
well as we do
there's always a surge at the end so we
have the um
i actually i don't know if you were
going to go but we're going to see what
the surge is at the end
and then also we set our campaign goal
too high
so we admit it is that what you're going
to talk about no but but i i agree with
that as well and
but one quick thing is for me
distribution isn't a sexy thing i think
making the film and raising the money
for it it's like when an ipo comes out
everybody wants to see it and they're at
the nasdaq and they're ringing the bell
and everything's so exciting
and they're watching the price go up and
then great and then
quarterly earnings come out and it's
boring unless you own that but like
you know what i'm saying it's not as
sexy a thing to distribute karen i think
i i know what you're saying
so well you know it's it's getting
heavily involved in distribution i'm so
excited about it and the top question
people ask me is
jason what are you going to make your
next movie and i'm like wait i really
like distribution
do you look good good i'm glad i'm
actually on the opposite side of what
well literally and figuratively
of what you guys are saying here uh
distribution you know we got to make it
sexy
yes we do i think it is uh okay well
good well
and i think it's a matter of choice and
what people are
best suited for and and i know for me
it's probably not one of my strong suits
but
i think that that may be one reason i'm
sure another filmmaker
another artist could probably do this
way better and and have
tremendous success because they have
more of an audience so hopefully we can
kind of be you know dip our toe in the
water with this and then somebody like
an amanda palmer or someone else could
come along
louis ck and and release it
much more i think you're doing a good
you know you're doing a good incremental
stepping you know in terms of your
projects you know
this wasn't you know batman this was
a small film and you guys have scaled
accordingly
yeah yeah here's here's one more thought
jason
cheryl um because we we did go with
indiegogo
and and and and we love indiegogo with
this opportunity to do what we're doing
wouldn't exist without indiegogo
and and also indiegogo gives us the
component of reaching people all over
the world
um you know but but there's a part of it
where
uh the indiegogo gold platform is not as
polished as
as as the kickstarter platform you know
so
um there's maybe some advantages and
some things and some momentum that we'd
be able to gain
on because from our experience from from
dealing with kickstarter
there's more of a community there um
there's a greater sense i think of
discovery there
um there's just there's just more things
that that we we
can take advantage of there that you
know we're having we're bringing a lot
you know we're bringing not a lot but
we're bringing some people to the gogo
platform that are literally signing on
um just just so they can contribute to
our film um
so so so there's a little bit there um
and then
and then you know we set we set this
this astronomical goal of a million
sort of views is what we're going after
a million contributors
mainly because it ties into the theme of
our film of going after the impossible
dream
you know and because we believe the day
is coming very soon when artists like
us who have this small work on this
passion project they're going to put it
in on a platform the way we are right
now and and you're going to see it just
skyrocket
so we kind of wanted to to to stay
claimed to that
and just and just you know just use that
as a way to maybe inspire the artists
out there that this is possible
um so we think with a with a lower um
threshold
um you know people would see that the
the goal is more
tangible and and maybe there would have
been more of a flurry so you know
you would say that that was one thing
you'd do differently next time um
especially for a distribution campaign
you'd set it a little bit lower
yeah yeah that's the definite one lesson
we definitely learned because
i think it intimidated a lot of people
they thought oh there's no way
um they'll ever make a million and i
think we we fully were aware of that as
well
but i think that could hurt someone from
pulling out their credit card
and and doing a dollar because they're
like they're not even close to it
whereas if you're almost there oh let's
be part of the process
let's get them to that goal yeah well
i'll be making my donation a little bit
later after this interview so
at least you're going to get another one
from me
i know our time is limited today but
just a couple more
questions about maybe maybe if you guys
can speak a little bit more
because you are kind of the pioneers of
using this
distribution strategy what would you
have done differently
aside from not raising such a lofty goal
but what else would you have done
differently
how could you have done it better you
know that we're still racking our brains
on that one right there
um i think it's going to take maybe a
few days to to kind of once the dust
settles a little bit
maybe more pre-leg work i think there
probably can't be
enough sort of before um
campaign planning that you could do and
we definitely reached out to many
outlets
acting outlets things like that um but
probably just
even more of that um
did you keep the filmmaking process
transparent as you were going through it
i mean were
uh the initial uh funders from the
crowdfunding campaign following you guys
throughout
yeah you know this this whole you know
our situation is
is we were making our film literally at
the same time that film courage
was was being born and became its own
entity so
because you weren't you weren't busy
enough with the movie you had to create
another outstanding website too
so you know the whole thing you know we
we thought you know this is like a
little
improv film that had no money that you
know literally we're just trying to
exercise just keep those creative juices
flowing
and so we thought like okay let's just
shoot this on the fly we'll have this
done within a year we'll just kind of
put this out there
and then we'll get ready for our next
film so so here here we are three years
later not anticipating that it would
take this long
and so um you know we've done our best
to maintain those those early
um supporters and we we've seen a lot of
people from our kickstarter campaign
um come over and support this one so
we've had people that have contributed
in both instances
which is okay so your initial campaign
was on kickstarter and then this one was
indiegogo
right yeah okay you know yeah we had i
think 227 backers yeah we've gone from
227 backers on our first one and now
we're over 300
and and we're just now in that sort of
beginning phase of our final flurry
we're down to like our last 60 hours so
yeah so this is this is our opportunity
to really try to drive that number
up and um and see how we can push it our
current goal is
to see if we can get up to a thousand we
realize that the million fan
um you know goal is not tangible like
people see that and they're just
and it may be like karen said it might
intimidate people yeah so in these last
couple of hours you know
the last hours we're going to just we've
made the concerted effort to say
we've alerted a lot of people with the
engagement that hey you know what we're
going to just try to go after a thousand
because we believe that's possible
um you know we do believe that's
possible and another thing with this
campaign we didn't mention in this in
this interview
is we took seven days off of our release
to help another filmmaker on his
kickstarter campaign
and so that campaign by jack marchetti
is called four of a kind
we were so compelled by his story of of
a young man
in his early 30s who's losing his sight
every day of his life he's been losing
his vision
and he's a talented screenwriter and he
wants to make a film before he goes
entirely blind right so no i think i've
seen that one
that interesting yeah yeah so
so we literally we were on the front
page of indiegogo featured
and we stopped pushing our own campaign
so that we could help him try to reach
his goal
how did he do did he reach his goal we
it went from 20 000 all the way up to
over
like 64 000. it was a hundred thousand
dollar goal and we came up short but
but but it trended on twitter twitter
you know it was it was crazy
it was crazy madness on twitter so
you know again i mean we feel badly that
we weren't able to fully
you know get them there but but still i
mean
maybe i'm asking the wrong questions you
know the interesting part about
indiegogo and
and you know full disclosure i do a lot
of work with distributor which is owned
by indiegogo so
everything i ask sounds so biased i like
indiegogo
and i do um a lot
but with that said you know one of the
benefits is you don't it's not an all or
nothing deal so
thankfully the gentleman you helped out
got to keep the 64 000.
and you know his was on kickstarter this
was on kickstarter
so he was you know he was able to raise
like 28 000 i think in the last day
but it still wasn't enough so he he has
no money right now
and and um we're hoping that he's going
to figure out a time
yeah so to get back out there try this
again and
we're gonna we're gonna do our best to
try to see him through see it through
and whatever his goal is we're gonna try
to get behind him once again and help
him
help him in that response my heart just
broke
um and so i guess that's another
conversation but keep me in the loop for
that when you guys go out and do another
campaign for him
yeah sure yeah that's all his sort of he
had his own team lucas mcnally from a
year without rent
was also helping yeah so yeah we'll
keep posting on that but yeah yeah
that's another reason why we went with
indiegogo is because we didn't want to
set this this sort of million fan
million dollar goal
and then put in all this work and then
at the end of the day not hit this
outrageous goal
and then not be able to to keep any of
the money you know so
um yeah so that that's another reason
why we went with indiegogo
what are you what are you guys going to
do next uh in in wrapping this up here
and and i'd also like to get some advice
that you could get in part to some of
the filmmaking stuff uh
viewers that may be interested in
getting to know you guys
uh so what are your next steps and then
what's your advice
we're still not sure what we're going to
do after this i mean we have
filmcourage.com
and then we do uh we have a video
component now we don't
do the radio show any longer but we do a
video uh podcast and also
video interviews so we'll continue with
filmcourage.com i mean it's a pretty
much full-time job
and we also work on top of it so our
hands are full with that
um yeah and in terms in terms of goodbye
promise um
really really we have to sort of um we
have to we have to finish this stretch
um you know we're hoping uh
you know i mean what we're hoping going
in is we're literally hoping that we can
we could have
enough create enough momentum and create
enough revenue so that we could take a
portion of this
and and go through a service like
distributor so we're really looking at
the strip and i know we haven't
totally highlighted this river in this
conversation in terms of what they are
but they're
they're an aggregator that can help
filmmakers get their their work onto
possibly itunes and hulu um you know
they have relationships with netflix and
amazon all that sort of thing
and so you pay a flat fee and and then
from there you keep all the the
percentages that come in they just don't
know that distributor takes their cut
and then from there you you hold on to
all the revenue from all
from all the the the platforms that
that your film ends up on so we would
love to sort of transition
to that point where we can then extend
our reach and our film is more widely
available to a larger audience
um but we have to kind of see what we do
here in these final hours
um but that's something we hope to do at
some point
in time um in addition to doing a
limited release dvd
and and getting those out to the people
that want to own it on dvd as well
and jason in terms of advice uh what
area were you thinking in terms of
crowdfunding or
well you guys have done a whole lot i
mean you've gone through the gamut from
from the crowdfunding the whole way to
production the whole way to to coming up
with these ideas for distribution
um so i guess yeah it's sort of a broad
question but i'd like
a lot of the readers on filmmaking stuff
there's two different types of folks
that
are just making their first feature and
then there's the seasoned filmmaker
that's been doing this for a while
um that's been through the rig of aurora
like we all have and and
has encountered some of those old
distribution deals that no longer work
how how would you or how do you suggest
that these filmmakers approach the
landscape
you know um you know the king
you know you know in terms of a beginner
filmmaker
um you know i mean we consider ourselves
beginner filmmaker you know
our our film is really small um what
we're trying to showcase is we're trying
to showcase that you can have an idea
you can have the passion you can have
the heart you can go out you can make
your film
um with it without any sort of
traditional means
and and now we're trying to showcase
that that you can go direct your
audience and have you know have
you know that this is viable that that
you can succeed at this sort of thing so
that's kind of where we are you know
it's hard for us to give um advice to
filmmakers who have more experience than
we do right probably
made more money things like that one
last thing too if you are going to build
deny and sometimes i think it helps to
to you know write or or tweet about
stories that are that are similar to to
the group that you're in
and not just have it all be your own
sort of video blog about okay well this
is what i'm doing today and this and
that and and
and build people along with you uh with
around other people's stories
and i think that's how film courage was
born we were so fascinated by some of
these other people's
journeys that we got swept up in it and
then just started tweeting and posting
articles and all that
and and built an audience that way yeah
you know and we
have the luxury of of we don't have a
ton of expenses you know
we're we're in the red but it's not like
a massive amount of money so we have
a little bit more freedom to be
adventurous
in our distribution path here so far you
know whereas a lot of people they have
films that have cost a lot more money
and they're not in a position to take
this route so what we realize what we're
doing is not for everybody
um but what we're trying to do here is
we're trying to show for that indie
artist
that was conservative with with how much
money they put into their film
and and didn't burn a lot of money
didn't you know and just they have
something
and if if the system is turning them
down and if they can't get their film
out
to the people in the way that they want
to get out um i think we're showing that
if you sort of roll up your sleeves and
put in some work
that that there's a new way um where you
can just start getting your film scene
that doesn't
doesn't cost you any money out of pocket
you know we haven't spent any money on
deliverables
we haven't spent any money on marketing
so so when you're looking at the
the you know when you you know like once
again you're looking at where our
numbers are just know
that this is no money that we've put
into this release right so
right well i
i think at this point i'm going to go
ahead and wrap it up
i'm jason from filmmaking stuff and
maybe you guys could go ahead
if it's the filmmaking stuff folks
watching this tell them how they can
find you
and also find your campaign oh okay well
you can find our site at filmcourage.com
we're also on youtube
film courage and then the site is uh
indiegogo.com
um is it forward slash goodbye promise
or or just goodbye promise.com
and and jason thank you we appreciate
you taking time to chat with us
you know we understand this was under
the gun and impromptu
spontaneous spontaneous you made
yourself available um we really
appreciate it thank you um
thanks to all your peeps at
filmmakerstuff.com and just to be clear
it's uh filmmakingstuff.com
i don't know who the other guys are oh
filmmaking stuff okay
i'm just going to bail out now and i got
to go i got to go buy another domain
real quick so
yeah call it go daddy right now and
charge you 50
for it okay thanks to my bag we
appreciate you sorry about that
okay oh it's fun good to meet you guys
take care
nice talking